the best way to describe Joe DiMaggio is
he's a penis with a man hanging from it
tonight it's huge right you know how he
used to when we were kids they called in
the shower shoes they called thongs did
they Joe wore three of them
[Music]
hey David Wells just came by
with his girlfriend Nina he's on his way
to another appearance I guess he did
Regis and Kathy Lee dying to see him
look at him man I was watching my TV
pitched that perfect game man you're on
a roll man I think I'm enjoying it while
I can you know and it's fun it is it is
fun man although it's exciting and I've
never expected any of this to happen
you're not getting a little crazy though
yesterday you told me these things were
happening a little too fast they are
that's why I said I mean it's
overwhelming but you know how do you
enjoy it you know not in a bad way but
it sucks to be me right now because I'm
neglecting all my friends I got a bunch
of calls I haven't called anybody yeah
but come on they understand
and you know what they're all going to
say that's not the way I am and they're
all going to say hey man you're a
scumbag you made it now you're not
calling me and this and that the other
thing it might be rough you never know
this is very funny this morning you know
I had your number and Gary tried to call
and he said your voicemail was full
I'm sorry this is too exciting man I
don't know what to do they can picture
perfect game then what do you do you
know when I wrote my books it's like 25
000 people would show up to book signing
people would say well how do you feel
how do you feel and I'd say I really
don't feel any different
you know what I mean I don't feel you do
for a couple days and then are you able
to enjoy this I am now yeah really I got
some good sleep to think about what you
know what went on and and what I've been
doing do you feel happy perspective do
you feel happy inside very happy you do
yeah it's like a dream come true wow
that's something that can never be taken
away it's not just a one season thing
that's forever yeah it's a history book
do you think this guarantees you a place
in um the Hall of the Hall of Fame no
just uh a hat what I really donated yeah
I gave him my hat what do you think
about Saturday's game you think you're
gonna do another perfect game no no way
no that's that's it I think you might do
it that's a that's what if you started
throwing perfect games like every time I
went into Twilight Twilight yeah
wouldn't that be weird and you know what
I'm going into hiding you could take
much more of this I'll do one more and
quit yeah that's enough yeah
when you were playing baseball you did
this thing where you would do like sort
of uh undercover work and you'd find out
everything on an Umpire if he was going
you know cheating on the wife gambling
whatever he was doing you'd find out
yeah and then you get up to bat
and you turn to the Umpire and you say
to the guy hey man
how was your road [__] the other night
yeah you're cheating on your wife and
you think that that made them give you
good calls right
um it gave them no option because uh
fear does a lot to a man so I I just
realized early that umpires controlled
my life meaning yeah I mean that's the
situation you know you try to you know
be nice to him you try to what but so I
just eliminated any risk of of them
having any control over my life because
like one of them would call a strike and
and I'd look back and say really
um what was it spread last night
so I mean but but again everything I did
was about
getting an edge because see I was never
supposed to
be a pro um well the thing about it
there's only 30 jobs in the world yeah
they're like if you're a center fielder
there's only 30 jobs in the world not
Florida and not New York not California
not Puerto Rico not Dominican Republic I
mean you could play college ball and all
that but become a pro and a major
leagues too because you have to then
take someone's job I mean it's hard
enough to get up there then you have to
take someone's job yeah because
somebody's already doing that job when
you show up right if they work their ass
off to get there to say yeah but people
don't realize is when you played for the
Mets the thing you didn't like is you
had to share the position with Moki and
it pissed you off you wanted to be a
full-time player so they would rotate
you guys right yeah it's the only way
they could you can't get paid if you
don't play every day but but you know
our manager was kind of uh you know he
was what's that guy's name again David
Johnson Davey Johnson and you went to
him and said I don't want to share my
position with mookie right no I just
said I got to play every day I can play
I said I mean like it was kind of weird
getting traded to Philadelphia like when
they just say you know a hey you're done
hey you got traded uh thanks for your
services then you go there full time and
it's hard to keep up so then you had to
do the steroids right yeah in order to
[__] just stay in the game it was too
hard on your body to play every day well
I'm a little guy I mean yeah I'm five
nine yeah but you're built like a brick
[__] look at you well I'm a little
bigger now but yeah you look like you
could kick some ass but five nine like
can I let the major leagues like twice
and hits how does that how did I do that
I mean not because I'm the best hitter
when you decided to do steroids because
you're playing for Philadelphia they got
you playing every day and you said my
body's starting to break down the weird
thing is you describe that everyone was
doing it and at that point steroids were
so available you'd walk into Rite Aid or
something and you were able to buy them
over the counter right yeah well I
didn't forget how to hit right I can
play the game you needed strength I
needed the durability and then I show up
in spring training and I mean I was I
had muscles in my face dude and then
what happens you just feel like like
you're a [__] God [__] I walked out
to like had a 15 inch [__] really it was
like you [__] you want me to bring it
[__] and they knew it the other
team knew
in your book by the way is this all
worth it is the book selling like crazy
this is like a national phenomenon
what's going on here I really didn't
know
how this book was uh going to influence
not just baseball but it's influencing
everyone in general but the players have
got to be pissed because they got it
because now McGuire must be on fire
right the only way to make this
completely valid names and I believe
eventually will happen one of these
players will come out of the woodwork
and agree with me listen my attack is
that not towards a player players my
attack is solely and strictly against
Major League Baseball and the player
association are they calling your
records into question then they might as
well call everyone
um
because in in the 80s and 90s it was it
was the steroid error and I don't know
what I'm saying is if they are you know
throwing you out and and
everybody right well I don't know I
don't know if they will or they can
because I'm the only one of one of the
very few who's admitted taking steroids
my main objective was never to attack
the players my main objective was to
attack Major League Baseball on the
player association the reason why I
named The Players is because I need
these individuals to come out and admit
that what I'm saying is your truth
um so what is wrong with major league
baseball and the Players Association
they allowed stairs in the game they
endorsed that they turned their you know
Blind Eye to it and because they were
all uh you know betting benefiting from
it financially tell me something uh you
think players who use roid should be
allowed in the Hall of Fame I don't see
how they're going to
chain I don't know that's the most
difficult question because I don't see
how they can judge will they keep you
out of the Hall of Fame I have no idea
you don't care I care obviously right
but it's out of my control okay how do
you let a guy who's taking steroids for
a long time into the Hall of Fame how do
you take if you say Barry Bonds has
taken them how do you take his career
and compare it to Hank Aaron they're not
the same career not comparing they
didn't play on the same field you know
what I mean they played in a different
way how do you compare records one guy
he got stamina from steroids the other
guy didn't have to compare records that
guy doesn't do everything it took to be
the champion oh come on it's illegal he
wasn't allowed to but in 100 yard dash
if I trip the guy next to me I've done
everything I can to win people are going
to be debating this for a long time
legendary battles you had with your
manager Billy Martin yes but you hated
him right you hated Billy Martin
I didn't like him I didn't waste my time
hating people it it's too much effort he
played mind games with you I mean he
wouldn't he didn't want well he you know
batting forth in the fourth position
cleanup as they say yeah he wouldn't let
it happen he wouldn't let Reggie Mr
Jackson do this right the way that I
became the cleanup hitter right is
Thurman Munson and Lou Pinella went to
Billy Martin's room in early August 1977
said Billy we're struggling uh you're
you're hurting the ball club by not
hitting this guy clean him get out of
the way and let him go and they and then
he listened wound up being 41 and 11 our
last 52 games I didn't realize you two
were at going at it
he never spoke to me for about a year
and a half first year and a half I was
there he had an intermediary Named Fran
Healy a catcher that came in like I
didn't play the fifth game of the
playoffs against Kansas City and Yankees
in 1977. okay I was benched and it was a
big National thing so friend Healey
comes out of the manager's office and he
comes to me and he says Reggie he says
you're not playing tonight I said really
I said well who's supposed to tell me
you you're the backup catcher and Frank
and Fran says no I was in there Billy
called me in he told one of the coaches
to tell you and he wouldn't tell you he
said so I'm telling you he said now let
me tell you what you need to do you need
to go out on a bench you need to not
active set you need to be a part of the
team the cameras are going to be on you
you make you you'll the people and the
fans will go against you if you act so
if you sulk or whatever he said so if
you have to pretend just just be rooting
for the team because you never know you
may get in there in in the ninth inning
we went in and got a pinch hit and
helped us win the game but must be a
great feeling man to be like you know Mr
I told you the Savior at the same time
Howard I never
was bitter about it I never did I Told
You So I did my thing it was obvious
everybody was happy and I I guess this
would be the first time that I would
have anything to do with I told you so
you should have did it the first time
you get yelled at still because they
consider you the guy who injured Alex
Rodriguez right you were doing a
baseball unbelievable A-Rod is talking
to you on the sidelines right yeah so I
walk out I'm with my sister's son jack
and I walk out of the Dugout and I'm
walking down and Alex who's become a
good friend of mine is standing there at
third base while they're taking batting
practice and he looks over to me goes
Hey Joe and I said hey Alex and I keep
walking he goes Hey Joe is that your boy
he's starting to say is that your boy
and and Lance Berkman who was playing
for the Yankees at the time hits a
rocket it crunches him right under his
knee oh man and he goes I mean like
running out one legged into center field
is rolling around in the grass and
center field grabbing his leg and my
sister son jack who's got this raspy
voice is like I don't think that's good
and I go up to the booth I'm I'm
standing down there and I'm like oh my
God I hope nobody saw me you know
talking to him right and eventually one
of the players said I know how he got
hurt he was talking to that that fox Guy
what's a buck what's his name and then
the then the horde of media guys turn on
me they're like what happened I said I
just walked out on the field he turned
his head to say hi and he got whacked I
mean I don't know what else to do so
people used to blame you for that it was
the cause it was the back cover of the
daily news oh my God it said what the
buck it was it was a game against the
Reds socks they took him out of the
lineup he didn't play the next night and
Yankee fans have never forgiven you
that's right they hate it I know we we
had we we interviewed like Yankee fans
they were like [__] Joe yeah he [__]
killed yeah yeah I mean all I did was
exist and I got motherfucked for that I
went to Vietnam with Joe DiMaggio right
and I actually gave him a shower One
Night in the middle of the Jungle
Joe DiMaggio well the only way it
happened were and we got men to tell the
story sure go ahead yeah okay you know
we we went from uh San Francisco to
Vietnam me Joe Jerry Coleman Tony
Conigliaro wow and they broke us up into
two groups and Joe and I went South and
the other two went North and we ended up
meeting them on the uh Intrepid which is
docked down here right and we're out in
the middle of the Jungle and it's so
damn hot you can't sleep I I just can't
believe Joe says I gotta take a shower I
said Joe we're not downtown Saigon this
is the middle of the Jungle so the only
way you can take a shower is they have
like a bamboo thing and somebody's got
to get up on a chair
and pour the water in and pull a string
and on the subway and Joe's taking a
shower right now the best way to
describe Joe DiMaggio is he's a penis
with a man hanging from it it's huge
right you know how he used to when we
were kids they called in the shower
shoes yeah Joe wore three of them oh wow
this penis was that huge oh my God it
was legendary Right check with a man
hanging from it believable how many
inches would you say Joe DiMaggio well
he said that ain't where it ends that's
where it bends
I got to be the only guy in the world to
give Joe DiMaggio a shower yeah was that
the biggest one you've ever seen I mean
you've been in locker rooms all over the
world yeah yeah he's he's uh did you say
that man did you say Joe my God Jesus I
tried if I'd hit a camera phone I took a
picture
how did that I mean he could have signed
Carl used on it
so you get out of college yeah or
whatever you didn't even graduate
college right you didn't finish I
graduated junior college so I have an
associate degree okay so you go there
and then I guess someone told me like as
a favor somebody let you sort of go
Tommy Lasorda is really really close
friends with my dad and how does a Shore
to know your dad they kind of grew up
together they're they're from Norristown
Pennsylvania and did you say to your Dad
hey Dad can you ask Tommy Lasorda if I
can try out yeah well what happened was
again I wasn't getting any exposure or
any right you know at all and and Tommy
obviously with his connections he said
well I'll have the Dodgers draft Mike as
a favor and it looks good on a resume
like if you go to a school like I could
go to University of Florida right be a
coach or something yeah it was well
they'll say yeah you've been drafted by
a team so we'll give you a shot to play
oh I see calling cards all right so like
you really wanted a shot because you
felt hey maybe I am a good baseball
player yeah I had the dream you know you
had the dream yeah but even though you
sucked in college you kind of knew deep
inside like if you put your mind to it
you could be good yeah I mean I knew I
had some talent because I would go to
you know knowing Tommy I would be apple
and stuff for the Dodgers when I was a
kid right hit in batting practice and I
would hit home runs and out of the park
and I'd be like I can do this like the
regular guys were you getting nervous
yeah you would get nervous definitely so
something was holding you back
definitely okay so let me understand
something so la sorta says to you uh-huh
all right kid because you're I know your
dad I'll let you try but me while the
sorta probably thinks you suck too and
he's just doing it reluctantly get it
out of the way he's like I wish the
whole goddamn family would leave me
alone with us already right yeah he's
been calling his Mark in ever since yeah
so he lets you like try out and you try
out and what do they do they put you in
like a double A baseball or something or
you go actually goes uh rookie ball a
ball double a triple A big leagues all
right so you were like in rookie ball
yeah all right so so you then how do you
get over the psychological thing though
that he's having well what happened was
I really started uh going to the gym and
training I started lifting I gained like
you know 15 pounds right got stronger
and then when I finally got a chance to
play they said okay hey you're hanging
around here long enough you're gonna get
one shot to play or you're out of here
good and then that's a way to relax here
yeah exactly right but then that's funny
you mentioned that because I just
relaxed I said hey you know screw it I
got nothing to lose nothing to lose have
fun and I hit 29 home runs in a ball wow
in Bakersfield so does the shore to call
you up and go hey maybe I wasn't such a
jackass for hiring you yeah
so that's a ball then they put you to
double a and Triple A and then in AAA
yeah exactly then what happened was then
I went to Mexico I played winner ball
right it was a big lift because I played
against a lot of guys that played in the
big leagues and next year I went double
a triple A big leagues in one year wow
in one year oh yeah and you start
playing for the Dodgers and all of a
sudden you become this great player just
yeah even say that about Michael Jordan
because like Michael Jordan wasn't so
great when he first started yeah it just
was the classic like late bloomer just
right you know just got calm and it's a
confidence thing because once you get to
that situation and you know you can do
it that's the that's half the battle
George Steinbrenner is the host of
Saturday Night Live that week in 19. oh
my God right yeah and this is George
Steinbrenner and he was at the a height
of you know he's George Steinbrenner the
Yankees he's the cliche that you know
from Seinfeld Larry David Play We want
to look to the Future we've got to tear
down the past Babe Ruth was nothing more
than a fat old man with little girl legs
and we were all scared of them we were
all terrified no one had thought of the
monologue and then there was some idea
for a monologue that wasn't even my idea
and it it became like doing KP Duty in
the in the service it was like someone
take care of this and I remember Lauren
saying Conan go talk to and go talk to
Steinbrenner and pitch in this idea for
a monologue you know and I don't even
remember what the idea was and what I
didn't know is that he had been pitched
this idea already and said no so I
remember I went in and Bob Odenkirk and
I were like the Young Writers were kids
we go into this room I have to do the
talking and I go in and I'm like it's
just time Brenner um yeah so this is
idea for the monologue where you like
come out and you lost the keys to the
car and you think maybe you know and he
said all right I told you I told you I
don't want to do that idea I already
said I don't want to do that idea and I
remember what I remember is he had this
massive World Series ring biggest ring
I've ever seen in my life
yeah and he looks like he has about 60
pounds of corned beef in his colon you
know one of those yeah beefy guys big
German guys he's like I don't want to do
this and I totally said I don't want to
do it I don't want to do it and so I
just Odin Kirk and I Retreat out of the
room and our testicles had gone up
inside our bodies and we go and we tell
Lauren and we say to Lauren he doesn't
want Lauren went you know you just have
to go back you just have to go back and
tell him you just have to go back and
tell him look it's a good idea and you
you've lost the car keys and then and
then you know it's a funny thing and
he'll understand and so Lauren just
wanted this problem to go away so he
sent us back oh so we go back into his
little dressing room so he's even bigger
because he's in a tiny space it's like
we're getting into a phone booth with
George Steinbrenner to tell him
unpleasant news we go into this tiny
room he sees the two of us and I go this
is time Hunter
um okay well we just think the thing
with the keys could be funny because if
you think about it and steinbrainer just
turned around and said I don't want to
do it I only sat in the window and I'm
not gonna do it and Odin Kirk and I [__]
ourselves and disappeared from the room
like we we literally went right through
the wall like ghosts
Gary threw out the first pitch I mean
for the Daily News newspaper to say
comment even on and out a picture it's
the single most embarrassing moment in
the history of first pitches Gary
dellabate we all know him as Baba Bowie
from the Howard Stern Show delivered
what has to be the most embarrassing
ceremonial first pitch in baseball
history Saturday he had been taking he
had been talking for weeks on the Stern
Show about doing this and Saturday he
finally got his shot here it is
[Laughter]
why did you do this well first of all
there's a couple of things going on I'll
let you do you know right away that that
was the like like
so why do you realize this is going
horrible so so I'm standing on the side
and I've got like eight minutes before I
have to go out there and I'm just
getting more and more nervous more and
more nervous I start to um do that thing
that I do you know her lips no dry
heaves
like when I get really nervous I start
to cough like I want to throw up oh gee
I didn't even know about that disgusting
yeah I thought you meant licking your
lips I start to get the dry heaves wow
so doing it inside the guy that's with
me from the Mets is looking at me like
I'm out of my [__] mind right when I
get it so I've been given so much advice
from so many different people some
people say
what kind of advice people say just go
out and throw it and don't pitch it so
people say go on pitch and what that was
was a bad combination
like of me saying I'll pitch it at the
last minute go now I'll just throw it
you didn't think it was gonna be this
big no no I didn't think it was going to
be this bad we got married I have Mary
and your son's been relocated yet
Witness Protection Program so so we get
home on Saturday and I'm really bummed
out Mary's like God like I've been
putting up with this for two weeks is
this gonna go on now right I go marry
it's all over the [__] news yeah
here's Gary from another angle you see
he didn't pick up his hand high enough
over his head or something and it
releases too
and now he knows the pitch has gone bad
right here there's a beaten man so I got
a buddy who works for Rawlings and he
knows all the players and he sent me
back a note this is probably the most
stinging one of all I got reports from
all the players it's worse than you
imagined oh my God so that means like
the players are like now it's like the
inside joke of the clubhouse but here's
the question will this go away
eventually or is this one of those
things that's just always going to be
very very prevalent on the show always
going to be very prevalent on the show
all right
foreign